diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert und
präsidium verfeinert mit crème fraiche
mild und cremig risiko place de france
[Musik]
in diesem film geht es um die liebe und
unsere vorstellungen davon
in diesem film geht es auch um unsere
sehnsüchte und träume und darum was wir
daraus machen
[Musik]
die monogame beziehung hat in unserer
gesellschaft einen hohen stellenwert und
die treue steht in beziehungen ganz oben
auf der liste
laut anonymen umfragen geht aber rund
jede zweite schweizerin jeder zweite
schweizer fremd
[Musik]
ergotherapie von fünf bis sechs prozent
thematisiert und treue im vorfeld das
heißt das thema so wichtiges thema
es stimmt dass wunsch und realität so
weit auseinandergehen gab mir zu denken
und ich beschloss den fragen um liebe
und treue sexualität und abenteuerlust
noch zu gehen
der zieht oder identität und geschichte
zieht es zwei oder vier oder zehn oder
20 15 bis 21
mit dem bett fixiert aber ist sie
längere sachen because the night stands
xii
als mir lena zum ersten mal von ihren
seitensprüngen erzählte staunte ich so
hatte ich das bisher noch nie gehört
dass man in einer festen beziehung lebt
und über jahre mit verschiedensten
männern heimliche affären hat die
geschichte von lena machte mich
neugierig und ich wollte wissen wie es
dazu kam
mädchen de oder über gerät was bedeutet
und eigentlich ist das nicht wichtig wer
tisch loyalität ist sehr wichtig für
mich aber loyalität verstanden nicht
unbedingt also bis körperlich sondern
emotional geistig und in dänisch nach
den vier jahren bis anders gesehen
also eigentlich ein klassischer fahrer
gesucht im 786 erleben immer für die
personalprofis empfinden ja national
cyber tür
das traue ich mich bewege ist heikel
dass sich meine protagonistinnen und
protagonisten nicht alle zeigen können
liegt auf der hand wenn sie zuhause
auffliegen könnten ganze lebensentwürfe
einstürzen
bei den wehren neben seiner langjährigen
ehe auch drei kinder betroffen deshalb
beantwortet er meine fragen per sms über
tage hinweg
[Musik]
was ist der reiz am seiten springen das
neue unbedingt der reiz des neuen
die erste berührung der erste kurs das
erste mal die hand im höschen wie riecht
sie
wie fühlt sich ihre haut an was tut sie
danach das sind ganze lebensgeschichten
in einem zeitraffer außerdem man lernt
doch mit einem neuen menschen immer auch
noch neue dinge kennen neue wohnungen
neue bars restaurants hotels man hat
vielleicht einen anderen blick auf eine
stadt
selbstverständlich geht es auch um sex
aber eben nicht nur
[Musik]
der wunsch eines tages der ganz großen
liebe zu begegnen und mit diesen
menschen durchs leben zu gehen er
schlummert in vielen von uns auch mir
träumte diesen traum familie gründen
das miteinander gewachsen und ich bin
davon ausgegangen dass irgendjemand das
war mir selbst
seit zehn jahren ist sie verheiratet
arbeitet in einer führungsposition und
hat zwei kleine kinder
mit der zeit habe man sich in ihrer ehe
auseinander gelebt und plötzlich war da
ein alter bekannter der um sie war und
ihr geben konnte was sie sucht
romantisierend das ist erotik messe
stellt sie was das aber lang die
therapieziele und jack a
obwohl sich immer mehr exotische war
womit sowie nie was auch wirklich
interessiert also aus dem markt sprach
sms mails habe mir immer höherer stelle
[Musik]
hochzeitsmesse in bern zum zwanzigsten
mal findet hier die hochzeitsmesse
marina talstadt während zweieinhalb
tagen wird in den messehallen die
traditionelle hochzeit zelebriert
dreimal täglich werden in einer
modenschau eine auswahl an brautkleidern
anzüge für den bräutigam sowie festmode
für die hochzeitsgäste gezeigt das
angebotsspektrum ist schier unendlich
es präsentieren sich hochzeits
musikerleben torten vom ostheimer über
die tischdeko bis hin zu den trauringen
gibt es alles was es braucht um den
schönsten tag im leben eines paares zu
feiern
das gibt sicherheit ja einfach immer in
tschita von ihm damit er zu bringen
die frau spaziert oder gegenüber den us
anbieter das sind das etui verliert und
das ist ja auch eine familie haben und
ja und es mir nicht mehr an den bezirk
st
ihr müsst die jungs sie und die
neujustierung ist mir kein begleiten
zusammenzuwachsen
wenn die zonen und jahr für jahr zur
ewigkeit und darum bin ich schon mal
schöne gedanken mit auf sylt mit tanz
[Musik]
an die 40.000 paare gaben sich
hierzulande im vergangenen jahr das
ja-wort
rund 39 prozent dieser ehen werden nach
durchschnittlich 15 jahren wieder
geschieden
inwiefern die untreue in diesem ganzen
eine rolle spielt interessierte mich
über 10 millionen ergebnisse präsentiert
mir die suchmaschine zum thema
seitensprung ranglisten wo ich die
besten seitensprungpartner finde werben
mit slogans wie könnt ihr eine affäre
dating plattformen machen mir das
fremdgehen schmackhaft alle sketche man
verabredet sich ungezwungen zu
gelegentlichen sex egal ob verheiratet
gebunden oder sinn
fertig ist sehr mit sehr schönen
schmuddelig da die del sie vor den
schöne attraktive etwas offener
kultiviert die art wie viel einfluss
haben diese plattformen auf uns und
unsere beziehungen die boden man kennt
sich mit geschichten dieser art aus der
paarforscher therapeut und buchautor hat
inzwischen auch das thema online und
treue und seine auswirkungen auf
paarbeziehungen und versucht das gericht
zwei freien träger vor allem account
sind sehr schmal ist wird einfach und
reuth sie wir haben die möglichkeit
hätte bedien plattform über die app ist
das heißt noch auf morgen bereits
potenzielle partner interesse hat der
sexuellen abenteuer damit schaffte
schritte und roy sehr viel einfacher
wieder rein pragmatisch und die andere
dimension
was ist überhaupt noch willens
ex-besitzer definiert sie als sexuelle
untreue kalium und treuen und heute mit
einer ganzen plattformen geht es ganz
stark war die tendenz der emotionalen
und treuen gefährten dort sache mit den
anderen person sehr intensiv sagte der
emotional inhalte durch sexuelle
sexuelle fantasien frage wo ist noch
traurig war schon branche fließenden
übergang eigentlich und das sind neue
phänomene kainberger dem ausmaß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich glaube die virtuellen möglichkeiten
haben das sexualleben und vielleicht
sogar unser verhältnis zur wahrheit
verändert gut der seitensprung ist wohl
so alt wie der sex selber aber die
auswahl die vielfalt und auch das tempo
sind ganz anders geworden
einfacher ist es geworden es ist nicht
mehr nötig das lächeln an der bar deuten
zu können was irgendwie schade ist viel
schneller geht es eine sms eine stunde
zeit und hopp ab in die kiste
obwohl ich habe auf diese art wunderbare
frauen kennengelernt
von deren existenz ich wohl nie erfahren
hätte gäbe es facebook twitter und co
nicht
es ist ja auch nicht falsch gerade der
schriftliche austausch kann hervorragend
sein bis man all das im gespräch
erfahren könnte würden wohl monate
vergehen
es ist ja auch einfacher über seine
sexuellen vorlieben und wünsche zu
schreiben als darüber zu reden
dort an besagter bar nach besagtem
allenfalls richtig gedeuteten lächeln
selbstverständlich ist bei weitem nicht
alles gold was glänzt
die selbstdarstellungen der virtuellen
welt passt bei vielen menschen nicht zur
realität
aber das system richtigen leben auch so
und am ende ist er dann immer war real
thing die chemie die stimmen muss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vorteil vor mehr oder vor augen einer
frau auf der plattform ist dass mehrere
große minderheit sie für mich dass eine
art eldorados sie dass sie kennen die
leute hört sich das nicht so vorstellen
dass die im realen leben keine abo
beamter im gegenteil die meisten sind
schon länger ihre beziehung und das
irgendwann mal grund entweder sich hin
da und der bob manno warte bis kriegen
nur größer sie dass man völlig egal
die werke geht und er sich endlich wohl
ihre beziehung aber bisher und die
möchte sie sehr froh dass es keine
komplikationen
und wenn man mit dem anderen nachher
risiko dass sie als kriterium das ist
doch nur mitglied der frau
damit sie aber nicht irgendwelche
ansprüche habe uns vielleicht noch ein
und froh dass diese findet und angst
aufzüge ich bitte meine sehr klug
[Musik]
wer sich einen seitensprung organisieren
konnte ist noch nicht unbedingt am ziel
denn oft fehlt das liebesnest doch die
branche hat auch hier längst das
passende angebot gefunden auf
seitensprungzimmer punkt ch finden
villiger in der deutschschweiz über 90
zimmer und studios in welchen sie sich
heimlich treffen können erwin anderhub
ist der betreiber der website
fernsehen mit video recorder dvd-player
daher hoch linie mit snacks
kaffeemaschine schrank mit getränk doch
hat sich hier nach unten herrscht noch
immer sitzen wenn man da falls nötig
kondomhersteller gratis zur verfügung
als nett bis zum wrestler wenn möglich
sollte gestoppt
die erste woche gefangen zu sein magen
macht genügend relativ ihr gegenüber
damit tag und auch über nacht gefasst
ja sicher unter der woche auf mehr als
am wochenende
und ich sage es im moment ist noch nicht
beendet
politik ist es mehr oder weniger
wochenend eher weniger ob sie ganz wenig
und was auch nicht so wahnsinnig auf die
schulferienzeit dass inter die meisten
entweder sind es wirklich die fähre oder
sind halt eine geschäftsjahr schließen
sondern sind die wochen und dem früheren
spitzel die zimmer welche erwin anderhub
vermietet können anonym
gebucht und besucht werden dies sei es
wohl auch was seine kundschaft besonders
schätze also ich habe früher noch wild
kam mir zeiten ebenso das ziel wie sie
hier so viel stahl zwei drei wochen
brauchen
72 dafür lässt sich wohl da ihre hohe
defizite chips dramen und dass es für
sie jetzt ja da gibt es immer wieder wo
immer wieder so dass gibt kommen einmal
die woche oder monat
mal geht es viermal in der kurz kürze
plötzlich kommen immer der heinz
vielleicht irgendwas geändert da der
situation und plötzlich nach einem
halben jahr und damit auch so wie es
vorher auch päpste lorca war dass sich
bei leber der bohrstopp per sms
da habe ich mir die frage fährt den sms
kann man in ostafrika und schickten
unterrichtes erledigt ja
[Musik]
wie gelingt es den leuten ihre geheimen
treffen und abenteuer über monate an
anderen leben vorbei zu schleusen
frage ich mich und ebenso wie man sich
das zurecht legt im kopf unabhängig von
der einige partnerschaft mit haye macht
kino delphi an important bornumer mir
gehört also das ist das macht die
spannung vor dem ganz also vieles viel
zu fliegen da ist eine top platzierung
[Musik]
weiter wie legt man sich das zu recht
ich weiß nicht wie das bei anderen ist
aber ich lebe da in einer parallelwelt
ich überlege mir in diesem moment nicht
wirklich was ich meiner partnerin an tue
wenn ich mich ganz auf die seitensprung
partnerin konzentriere dann findet mein
leben genau dort statt
für mich ist das auch eine flucht aus
dem alltag keine steuererklärungen
ausfüllen kein ärger mit den
mitarbeitern keine kranke katze und ja
das sind dann oft auch lügengebilde doch
allein schon deren konstruktion ist eine
oftmals wunderbare geistige
herausforderung etwas so ganz anderes
als tatort am sonntagabend oder brunch
bei der schwiegermutter
erstaunlich ist dabei ein schlechtes
gewissen habe ich erst in dem moment
wenn die tür hinter mir zu fällt wenn
ich mich auf den heimweg machen
vorher keine sekunde
im gegensatz zu lena und ben machen mir
das doppelleben und versteckspiel zu
schaffen
und das deshalb nicht unnötig denkt
[Musik]
super dann fing einfach wenn ich zurück
einen qualitätssprung
die situation ist extrem und baby wollte
ja also mir liegt die ganz am anfang
suchen irgendwelche alibis und als
[ __ ] und hat die schlechteste wissen
es besser und e mails wurde die nicht um
sanierte frau die nach der katastrophe
zu
jetzt hat es wenn es schwierig wird in
dreiecksgeschichte tritt maya onken auf
den plan sie dann buch zum thema
geschrieben und führt seit zehn jahren
sos affäre eine beratungsstelle für
menschen in dreiecks konstellationen
also es ist wirklich so alle drei
positionen hand große not aber andere
oder geklebt position dass ich immer
nummer zwei und muss immer warten die
erich aufwartet russischen und das kann
einen fertig machen oder und immer aber
fest steht ist man ganz deutlich nummer
zwei und wenn dann eben die karotten
oder karotten ist den handel mit extrem
zu besetzen sein schwert merke dass zum
beispiel das lied ein betrunkener ist
natürlich ganz wunderbar weil er oder
sie visionen vom bezirk sind säumigkeit
aber aussieht springer hur stress was
sie alles mit und holt parken und die
verschiedenen ebenen dominant bei
unmöglich toni ob es andere lebewesen
also diesen immer offen extremen energie
high level und unter stress dass es
nicht unser hund
offenbar ist es nicht einfach über jahre
in einer monogamen beziehung zu leben
dennoch hat sich die monogamie
weitgehend durchgesetzt gefestigt wird
sie bis heute durch soziale religiöse
und moralische normen schwören wir also
unsere partnerinnen und partnern ewige
treue
obwohl das unsere natur widerspricht
sind wir monogam oder zwängen wir uns
nur in ein gesellschaftliches korsett
erzeuge tier darf ein ganzer linie
monogamie rat der bitte auf 14 20
prozent der säugetier sims 3 prozent das
heißt mit relativ wenig war wirklich
monogam transaktion revolution mäßig
alle der meinung nach kommen vom achten
müsste man sagen die wahrscheinlichkeit
für monogamie das sexuell das ist stehen
was er eine sexuelle monogamie gesehen
wird aus der frauen mit einer uhrzeit
von menschenstrom keine möglichkeit sich
zu reproduzieren
damit mir das übel aber von der
mainspitze sicheren und da gibt es
anders system das bindungssystem wo man
bei ganz stark bochum muss gelebt war da
und das große rolle gespielt
im sinn von zwei menschen zusammen will
steifigkeit raten viel zu hoch ist als
gruppe der schule gegangen die zu wissen
heute gezielt ob es vielmehr dass
binding und sexualität selektion
oberhand und damit wir das ganze
hochkomplex und die frage ist der
monogamie ist für darf sexuell
eigentlich nicht aber wenig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weiter geht's mit den klischees sucht
man sex ausserhalb wenn es in der
beziehung nicht mehr klappt schwierige
frage
der sex in einer langen beziehung
tendiert doch dazu sehr häufig nach dem
gleichen muster ab zu laufen und dass
man frau dann vielleicht etwas
abwechslung sucht ist doch irgendwie
verständlich die bedürfnisse können sich
ja auch auseinander entwickeln und dann
kommt halt dazu dass ich bei meiner
gattin gar nicht das bedürfnis verspüre
andere spielformen auszuprobieren
irgendwie gar nicht will dass sie kein
höschen trägt damit ich sie fünf
sekunden nachdem die haustür ins schloss
gefallen ist auf dem küchentisch vögeln
kann was aber und dessen bin ich mir
durchaus bewusst auch an meiner eigenen
kleinbürgerlichkeit liegen könnte
oder ist es vielleicht so dass seiten
springerinnen und seitenspringer gar
nicht auf der suche nach einem gegenüber
sind sondern vielmehr auf der suche nach
sich selbst
neues revier sexualität aber das ist
wunderbar safaris ist ja immer schön zu
finden als auch anders geht unsere user
egal ob im bett oder schals mensch das
ist bisher aber wenig bietet sachen
normal stellen sich neue kunden zu
finden und der fahrer ist möglich
gefasst hätten sich zu betonen
der anspruch dass ein mensch über 50
jahre hinweg alle unsere bedürfnisse
befriedigen und abdecken kann ist hoch
und vielleicht ist die idee dass es auch
in der sexualität immer stimmig ist und
auch bleibt tatsächlich zu romantisieren
wir legen natürlich dass ex japan ist
desto mehr gibt es sogenannte stärke
erosion
das heißt neue sexuelle neugier
attraktiver asexuell bekannt das ist
visuell das ist auf ganzer ebene
ähnliches phänomen bekannt ist und damit
sie natürlich jetzt gefallen wenn die
sexualität im schlaf das ist von den
genannten und das ist später meister ktv
mit einem beschleunigten die ohnehin
sind genau gleich betroffen wie leben
die hier die variation des belags ganz
frische gefehlt und davis wegen ansätze
der prävention
es ginge in langjährigen beziehungen
also darum sich als paar immer wieder
freiräume zu schaffen um sich auch
sexuell gemeinsam weiterzuentwickeln
stattdessen lassen sich wie ihre partner
immer öfter auf online chats ein und
pflegen beziehungen in der virtuellen
welt zum teil sitze die begriffe boni
bereiche dem 10 miteinander im andere
und weil die oder drei und ließ bohrende
und das rennen und freue mich dass heißt
stadt diez nutzer führen entweder
energiepolitischer insgesamt ist das
rausgeholt diesem etikett fälscher dass
sie panisch auf die investiert würde
weitere fremde person teilt und ganz
hilfe ist die emotionale exklusivität
noch falschen stück wichtigen aus die
sexuell über diese inland ihnen vermisst
und den sprechern um so schöner trend
war hatte das heißt fahrens dem sexuelle
untreue wählt das heim auch und verladen
contilia bei dass die ganze bin die
gleiche frage gestellt wie das macht das
ganze so explosiv
auch die sexual forscherin andrea burri
befasst sich seit jahren mit den themen
rund um liebe treue und sexualität
deshalb fürchten sich so viele vor der
sexuellen und treue des geliebten
menschen
wenn man sexuell gefärbte laub dann ist
es schon so dass das bindet und dass du
das wirklich angst davor dass wenn sich
zwei menschen schlussendlich wäre aber
nie begegnet das ist ehrlich und
erstaunt
das heißt eigentlich verlust aus ich
glaube dass nach wie vor nicht trennen
sex und beziehung sagt das ist wirklich
nicht einfach so vor allem aber gar
nicht aus dem konzept
das ist für mich aber das ist egal wo
sie gar nicht weiterdenken und sie weder
gedanken gar nichts cent bringen
weitergedacht und die traditionelle
monogamie hinter sich gelassen
das haben petit und franziska sie sind
seit zehn jahren verheiratet und haben
für sich die ideale beziehungsform
gefunden
offen und frei jede das wirklich machen
wasser hin sieht das zum nachbildung der
jp morgan wieder reich oder wasser wie
man vorgeht dass das am anderen
burkhardt logische ließ aber bei meinem
anderen etwas vorschreiben was stewart
hat er selber treffen entscheiden wir
was er will tut das ist so viel schöner
dass wir da beschränkt wird also ohne
regeln halten beziehung und regeln wo
alles sein kann und sein dorf und wo mit
dem anderen das kennt wenn es ihm gut
geht weil wir ihn erlebt
liebe das große wort das magische gefühl
wie definieren wir liebe für viele hat
sie etwas mit exklusivitätsrechte oder
sogar mit besitz zu tun für pc und
franziska hat liebe viel mit freiheit zu
tun was sie alles auf dem tisch mit der
befragten strom- und ich glaube das ist
für mich ist es ganz
also das ist für das ganze das ist alles
klar und offen ist und das vertrauen
herrscht also dass ich wenn ich mit
einem anderen mann jetzt schöne
begegnung habe dass ich das kann ich
alles mit ihm teilen steht seit ich sage
ja das steht ja nicht verlieren
wie macht man das das müssen wir die
tibet um mode und so machen oder claudia
bolla dann verliert man sich nicht offen
und da ist etwas passiert
wer liebt lässt in anderen frei diese
forderung kam ende der 60er jahre von
den linken intellektuellen die
hippiebewegung verachtete jede
einschränkung und wollte das
kleinbürgerliche besitzdenken überwinden
was könnten die gründe sein weshalb sich
die idee der freien liebe nicht
verbreitet und die sexuelle befreiung
nicht weiterentwickelt hat
[Musik]
ich bin überzeugt es geht um die
einzigartigkeit wo jeder mensch möchte
ich will und ich will nur 1,2 oder neuen
platz teile mit opel und der
einzigartigkeit sind oft lüth mit baby
zum teil falsch verwechseln
und darum ist das immer so einen höheren
stellenwert und vanessa sage ich ein
ganz wenig bei 5
dass sie offene beziehung gelebt und es
funktioniert denn der wunsch nach
einzigartigkeit und exklusivität könnte
mit unserem uhr bedürfnis nach bindung
und sicherheit zusammenhängen
bevor sich petit und franziska
begegneten haben beide über jahre in
traditionellen monogamen ehen gelebt aus
diesen verbindungen haben beide auch
erwachsene kinder ein thema welchem sie
in der vergangenheit immer wieder
begegnet sind ist die eifersucht und
über die eifersucht haben sie inzwischen
einiges herausgefunden wenn ich
eifersüchtig spielern habe ich das
gefühl ich bin nicht genug ich bin nicht
genug für den anderen der andere könnte
man weglaufen können die in verlieren
und selbstwert willst du also als katze
mit dem und natürlich nur toller und
dann ist da nur besser und dann hat er
noch besser rauter und weise so blöd
sind und angst dass meine beste ist
conti mir und was macht frau nach
schweren sterns ok das ist das gehört
dazu auch zum spiel nach entweder sich
ihk im moment passiert gar nichts
quatsch und äcker bestellen dann
passiert wirklich nicht oder wenn man
wie lebendig sind offen ist dann kann
kurz und schlecht um vorn
das ist eine top bands gehört alles dazu
offenbar lässt sich in diesem haushalt
niemand von verlustängsten irritieren
und irgendwie hat das wohl wirklich mit
einem gesunden selbstwert zu tun
ich habe das gefühl ich bin einfach das
beste was ihr passieren konnte also dass
das ist so also allgegenwärtiges zu
grundvertrauen dass ich habe
und wenn er sich da mal eine jüngere
verliebtheit oder was dann dann merke
ich dass an dem wir es mir erzählt oder
beratungshotlines wenn sie sich verliebt
hat meint dann ab da ist es sowieso von
ihr schwärmen ist oder und dann ja aber
da ist war bis jetzt noch nicht die
angst okay dann können die ermittler
gehen auch wenn das passiere und
jederzeit ob die jetzt bist oder nicht
du kannst deinen more oder dein partner
immer verlieren egal ob die infos im
gegenteil gegenteil je mehr die ihn am
tisch devils und behalten willst uns im
jahr stehen ja eigentlich von mir weg
weil also ging es mir jedenfalls je mehr
mich angestarrt und versucht festhalten
dass der brauch ich meine freiheit
[Musik]
nach dem besuch bei pc und franziska
frage ich mich einmal mehr inwiefern das
dogma der monogamen beziehung wirklich
sinn macht wo sich doch an die 50
prozent der leute sowieso nicht daran
halten können
hierzu schaltet sich auch wenn wieder
mal ein
unsere gesellschaftlichen normen
inklusive exklusivrechten sind von
christlichen vorstellungen geprägt und
die sind wie wir aus 2000 jahren
geschichte wissen schleierhaft
entschuldige mich da allfällig gegen
deine gesinnung schreibe es mag
egoistisch klingen doch am schluss sind
wir für unser eigenes glück zuständig
natürlich ist ein seitensprung
egoistisch es geht um das eigene
vergnügen
doch was ist grundsätzlich dagegen
einzuwenden
es profitiert ja auch meine umwelt davon
wenn ich zufrieden bin befriedigt mich
gut fühle weil der seitensprung nun aber
die gefühle der umwelt also der
partnerin verletzen kann bin ich
eigentlich dagegen dass man es zu hause
erzählt es kommt nur äußerst selten gut
es geht laut juni wohl nie mehr geliebt
und möchte klare tisch und dänisches gut
dass man da macht nur dort dazu hätte
ein tipp wenn man klare tisch machte man
einfach müsse dass man da vis á vis a
vis á vis wirklich hübsch geburt
verletzt und das tier person wo man
meint man kenne sie wird die drei
sekunden also es tut wirklich seine
waffen aus dem haus notfall tippens
telefon dass toni drohen wenn bei oder
die usa statt weil denn wirklich an apps
abgewogen sich damit vorstellen
[Gelächter]
ein großteil der seitensprünge fliegt
früher oder später auf fliegen sie nicht
von selber auf hilft zb detektiv erich
wunde die nach sein business lebt zu 70
prozent von misstrauischen eheleuten für
die überwachung von vermeintlich
untreuen arbeitet er mit gps tracker die
das bewegungsprofil von autos
aufzeichnen
bevor mir da schon die sätze wohin die
fahrt mit dem auto des conti wahnsinnig
oder sieht die zwei direktive denn
nehmen wir natürlich schon mal führer
momentan zum morgen fängt man da
irgendwelches muster wo gott oft eine
demotivierte gott fremd und dann haben
wir die krise somit und meistens immer
zwei sätze dann ein dritter mann
gefunden wird dann suchte personen
sicher nicht ein zweiter treffer
der rektor wunderling also tv zeigt dass
sie so zum beispiel jetzt hinter morgen
für die sonne zieht kuh mitmacht will
wann sie mit meiner mal machtlos ist
verhältnis hatte nachher buch
zigarrenklub länger ich vermute er sich
mit der kolleginnen gewachsen
naja so kraus interview griff die events
weiter nach dann kannst du so betrügen
ich höre jetzt einfach auch ihre stellt
sie nicht viel glücklicher wie fragen
sie einfach die macher war will man sie
sitzt will frau gibt den posten auf was
sie macht und was passiert wenn sich ein
verdacht erhärtet wir sagt fortwährend
am grund was läuft was gold ab was
passiert mit den neuen schätze wieder
mal wieder vor und drohen zeigt teile
ich dann okay das land mehr ich möchte
jetzt das material vorlegen und dann
schicke mir krankheit erlegen kann die
fäden zu dem lied hat im datenschutz
sondern geben ihn zu usa nach büro- und
mir zeigen die vom laptop zeigen wenn
der vorteil filmmaterial und gewinnen du
musst kantige will nach 24 stunden
wieder das aus wieder gelöscht aber sie
könnten von einer bilder entscheidung
getroffen was bei betrogenen abgeht wenn
ein detektiv den verdacht auf untreue
beweisen kann
von diesen geschichten haben die meisten
von uns schon gehört dass ich meistens
direkt was ist jetzt nun wirklich und
mit dem verbundenen ganz misstrauens
geschäft also wenn ich nur vertrauen was
kann ich nur ernste was hat jetzt dem
person ja schon alles zeit und immer
stimmt und es ist oft der misstrauens
schlimm stichnoth unbedingte sexuelle
trend gehackt dafür nur einige sehr gern
okay also blöd gegangen und aber
emotionale uns vertrauen weil mir ich
mit ihm im bett oder und auf eine denke
ich kann die person
zwar hätte mir alles erzählt was im
jahresvergleich wahrheit hinter der show
alles gemacht jahre lang und ich hatte
gemerkt und von dem her das ist schlimm
stehen
[Musik]
was ist wenn man erwischt wird
oops das kenne ich seit dem fest
verbandelt sein ist es mir zweimal
passiert einmal last die gattin mein
tagebuch und kürzlich stand eine
liebhaberin vor der tür
ich war nicht daheim nein es war gar
nicht gut
seither hängt nicht nur der haussegen
ziemlich schief aber ein solches denkt
man eher nicht
obwohl man müsste so rein von der
wahrscheinlichkeit her muss es hin und
wieder passieren
nein nicht die momente die man wirklich
braucht im leben
[Musik]
sexuelle untreue spieler als
scheidungsgrund häufig eine bedeutende
rolle
lese ich was hat es damit auf sich und
wirkt sich der internet zeitgeist auf
die scheidungsrate aus egal wer in der
historisch und treue jetzt massiv zu
kleine technische des phänomens ist
einfacher und die online möglichkeiten
vergeben
darum werden wir aber die überhand und
30 1 sein können
dessen ungeachtet seiner therapie von
fünf bis sechs prozent thematisieren und
treue im vorfeld das heißt das thema wo
ich auch zu zeitig führt wenn wir
allerdings mal wirkt ist wirklich dumm
trade ursache des übels ist meistens
nicht bloss acht und ist meistens der
auslöser für die entschied sich scheiden
will zustands des gesamten max anders
gesehen
[Musik]
auch wenn ein seitensprung nicht der
hauptgrund für eine trennung sein muss
loest untreue in beziehungen oft eine
große krise aus und krisen gemeinsam zu
meistern müssten sich aber paare über
jahre auch gemeinsam weiterentwickeln
und dies scheint in zeitalter der
selbstoptimierung eine der größten
herausforderungen zu sein
die paare reden nicht sie reden schon
mit dem betten bieten an die schon immer
meisten stille oder also sie sehen nicht
was sie von den man sich wünscht sie
reden nicht über ihre bedürfnisse nicht
über ihre sehnsüchte
sie hängt gar nicht gelernt oder
zwischenhoch wie wir leben die sonst
lange drum set your zueinander und das
land und das lange bemüht weil
ehrlichkeit essbar macht auch in
entwicklung neben dennis mal frisch
verliebt ein grund für esta machine oder
denn der stress mit seinem haus oder
ihrer hypothek oder krank
da kommt man immer mit eine neue tempo
wenn da nicht jedes mal neu ist die
buche da immer gut für mich oder wenn
man mal davon handle oder wenn man so
machen wird ganz schnell unpassend uns
ursprungs kostüm wo sie sich geständig
sofort ein und passte niemand denn ist
es wie klar auf der hand das ist einmal
irgendwann einmal nach vielleicht
jahrelang als enge kostüme torturen
normal findet so jetzt 10
die akten an
[Musik]
mias heimliche affäre ist eine von
unzähligen was sie menschen in ähnlichen
situationen empfehlen würde wollte ich
noch wissen
mir war der filmgeschichte 24 liter
wasser was mir passiert ist passiert
genau der freundin sei etwas 15 display
kaputt macht und 3 grad schlagwort ich
weiß dass meine absicht bands wie stabil
ist und wie gut ist dass man das
natürlich dass man auch abschiedsworten
dabei hat also seine nummern auf das
fokussieren
sofort werden das nächste mal trifft
sich morgen um hannover trafen zu
treffen sondern von alaba wetterlage
[Musik]
auch lena hat auf ihren streifzügen
etwas für sich herausgefunden
ich glaube es war richtig cool geht es
eigentlich nicht weil man immer
irgendwie asics emotional verhärtet oder
die andere person bringt regen rucksack
limit und mit dann muss man sich immer
schlauer als ich sehe das ist nicht nur
schöne bild womit sie etwa virtuell ist
es die person lebt also es wird ein
mensch aus fleisch und blut
sobald du die person trifft mit einer
ebene schwächen und stärken der fast
garnicht keine schule sehen
dass die monogamie nach wie vor einen
derart hohen stellenwert hat hat mit
unseren traditionellen moralischen
vorstellungen zu tun
und bestimmt auch damit dass es nur
wenige wagen neue wege auszuprobieren
wenn man fragt ich monogamie oder
polygamie natürlich oder zu wichtig als
normaler wenn sich die frage auf eine
einfache antwort ab und ich glaube die
einfache antwort haben wir so nicht in
anspruch sondern einfach jahren durch
die richtlinie braucht oder nicht weil
damit als auch wirklich im raum
[Musik]
petit und franziska haben für sich einen
weg gefunden ihre bedürfnisse nach nähe
und geborgenheit und die sexuelle
abenteuerlust unter einen hut zu bringen
ihr beziehungsmodell ist ein beispiel
von vielen alternativen welche wir
ausprobieren konnten
ein rezept wie die ideale beziehung
generell aussehen könnte haben sie aber
nicht
ich glaube das kann man nicht so vor
allgemein und für manche mag das gut
sein monogramm zu sein weil es beiden
gut tut und für manche eben einfach nett
und der mensch ist individuum und ihre
braucht was anderes was anderes zu essen
eine andere art von liebe andere art von
beziehung zu und ich glaube die kunst
ist den anderen der das anderes lebt
netze vorteilen wird das wie er es macht
also ich würde jetzt nie gehe und jemand
die im gegenteil wenn jetzt jemand 50
auf weit ist und sehr wirklich noch
glücklich ist ist wieder fährt einmal zu
selten dass man solche polemik
weinmeister hatte er das gefühl gottes
willen
wie leben wir nur noch nebeneinander her
und es gibt die nach 50 jahren immer
noch glücklich miteinander sein gut ab
gut ab weil beziehung ist arbeit also
die haben wirklich was geleistet in
ihrem leben und haben sich miteinander
auseinandergesetzt und ja immer noch
zusammen
mehr denn je frage ich mich inwiefern
unsere vorstellungen einer romantischen
ewigen liebe lebbar ist und ich ahne
dass wir eingefahrene denkbaren
verlassen müssten wenn wir wirklich
lieben und gemeinsam alt werden wollen
[Musik]
das wäre das besitzdenken überwinden und
uns um einen erweiterten begriff von
treue bemühen sollten eine treue die
sich vor allem als treue zu sich selbst
versteht als ehrlichkeit vertrauen und
freiheit die wir einander als liebende
schenken
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von präsident lugo mehr verfeinert mit
crème fraiche bild und cremig risiko
plaisier de france